I'm Leo Villareal I'm an artist based in
New York and I've created a piece called
light matrix MIT that's installed over
at the Sloan School this piece consists
of a matrix of stainless steel rods
there are 240 rods total so it's a three
dimensional array and each rod has 72
white LEDs embedded in it and I have 255
levels of brightness per led the other
important component is the software
there's a tool that we've been working
on for over 10 years that's custom
designed to create sequences so I'm
gathering those sequences and then
combining them into more elaborate
compositions and in the end those
sequences are displayed in a random
order for a random amount of time I've
been here working on the fine-tuning of
the piece it's site-specific so it's
very important for me to be here you
know get a sense of the place so I'm
looking at the ambient light levels the
level of activity to find the right
tempo and brightness so it's really like
almost like tuning a musical instrument
working with light is I mean it's so
primal light is a very seductive
material so people are drawn to it we
have this deep as humans this very deep
response to it so I'm interested in the
on equalities and you know when you're
staring into a campfire tapping into
that I think is very powerful and
something that you can't decode either
I'm playing with the the compulsion
pattern recognize you start to recognize
something but then it changes and it
could become something else it's a
little bit of a game and that you're
you're putting information out there
it's not quite complete but this whole
process I think is somehow pleasurable
to look at and to spend time once mi
t--'s always been a sort of mythological
place for me and I visited here many
times and been so inspired by so it's a
really great honor to be here to work
within this context I'm interested in
the livability of the piece creating
something that can fit within the fabric
of the architecture of applause of the
building and be something that really
contributes to people's lives and on
campus and we'll see what happens
you